- Ça c'est la c
♪ ♪ ♪
- Bisma Ansari et son conjoint
sont fam2020. Ils ont hébergé sx
enfants à ce jour.
BISMA ANSARI,
famille d'accueil, DPJ
- Ça nous apporte un senss.
- Ils ont par exemple vu
une fill8 ans d'abord
timide, s'épanouir au cours
des deux dernières années.
elle a beaucoup d'amies autour
d'elle. Elle se laisse aller
comme un enfant, comme ses
amies.e
Bisma Ansari, la De la
protection de la jeunesse.
Sur le territoire du CIUSSS
de l'ouest-de-l'île de Montréal,
la pénurie est préoccupantennai.
MARIE PIERRE ULYSSE, gestion.ceS
- J'ai 13 familles qui
pourraient recevoir des enfa
aucun de ces enfants-là n'a de
correspondance avendance avendas
que j'ai. Par contre pour être
en situation saine, je devraisq.
- Donc si jamais on a un autre
enfant.
- Trouver des familles estis
que l'esprit de laloi
sur la protection de la jeunesst
placées au même endroit.
Bisma Ansari et son conjoint
peuvent le faire, mais ce n'est
- Oui on veut que la fratrie
soit ensemble, mais est-ce qu'il
y a des familles qui sonte plusn
enfant, puis ça c'est la partie
qui est le plus gros challenge
pour le moment.s familles
d'accueil et des ressources
intermédiaires du Québec croit
que la DPJ devrait revoir so der
attirer de nouveaux candid
et mieux les soutenir une fois
sélectionnées.ÈVE RIOUX, prés.,.
familles d'accueil, Québec
- De mettre leurs exigences
aussi élevées, bien ça fait en
qui disent, c'est pas rare qu'on
va me dire bien Ma
peut-être à ma retraite.
- Malgré tout Bisma Ansari
même si ce n'est pas tous
les jours facile.
- C'est tellement gratifiant.
- Ouvrir les portes de sa maison
et aussi de son coeur à
des enfants qui en ont besoin
Radio-Canada, Mon